I'm only about two badasses is called to
guns make sense well what about the
scenes for the both going done McKim bow
and they're both using two guns isn't it
four guns even though it's still two
people think about it two guns so two
guns stars Mark Wahlberg and Denzel
Washington and there is a plot point
involving both of them but the trailer
spoil if I say spoil because if you
didn't know going into the movie would
be much more interesting so I'm not
gonna tell you about it here for two of
you out there who didn't see the trailer
you will enjoy this movie most you're
welcome but ultimately they robbed this
bank it's like 40 million dollars and
you yeah they robbed the wrong people
forty million dollars yeah bad folks are
coming and now they have to work
together to get out of this pickle that
they're in and the one who's coming
after them you know the Darth Vader of
Texans scumbags Bill Paxton so he shows
up in his old king over man he's like
shooting him in the kneecaps bill paxton
was awesome in this movie he had so much
fun in the world you could tell it I
enjoyed him I really enjoyed everyone in
this movie really that's one of the big
strengths in this movie Mark Wahlberg
and Denzel Washington both were
individually awesome they had good
chemistry together
Denzel it doesn't matter what Denzel
does you can phone it in big-time in
every movie is in you're still gonna be
like dude it's just a badass actor I'm
just saying the dude gives a hundred and
fifty seven percent in every performance
that he does Mark Wahlberg's character
was my favorite character in this entire
movie he was the relatable average guy
but he was a badass when he wanted to be
and he was kind of slick with the chicks
and he was funny and sarcastic you
always had equipped to say you're like
this is the man's man right here any
dude who watches his movies gonna be
like hija Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch
and the movie has a lot of plot twists
and turns to keep you guessing and keep
you entertained but the thing about
these plot twists and movies like this
there's a fine line between stylistic
plot twists that keep the movie
interesting and overly bloated
convoluted mess of a movie this movie
does ride the line in that a little bit
sometimes like you pull it back actually
a couple of these little plot twists
could go ahead and get left out of the
movie to make it a little more cohesive
and it'd probably be better movies still
fun I'm just saying that's in there the
movies directed by the director of
contraband it does have that same
contraband type feel where you feel like
the director kind of overplayed his hand
in some parts really like I get it you
want to be clever you want to make the
next like Ocean's eleven crossed with
way of the gun but don't make it look
like you're trying so hard sometimes and
the movie did have conveniences denzel
Jax's vehicle no one really saw him do
it he gets to this house no one saw him
stroll
up there then bill Paxson's questioning
someone he was like this vehicle was in
your driveway and denzel's driving it I
was like how do you know that how did
you know that can we think of texts and
Darth Vader [ __ ] with guns played by
Bill packs and had the script readily
available he'd be one step ahead of him
every time and just go to the next place
that Denzel is gonna go to and shoot him
in the face when he opens the door the
scripts like the Almanac from Back to
the Future to if you get you add to guns
is a fun August movie how August movies
in July movies have different vibes like
July movies it's like this summer is
really trying to really in August movies
like yeah a couple movies are gonna be
awesome but for all in all you see the
summer's dying down still trying to
entertain you but it's not it's a game
but I think of the movie that really
grabbed me in the summer 2013 I'm not
gonna think of two guns not gonna think
of a lot of movies that came out this
summer really Mark Wahlberg and Denzel
Washington both kicked ass it's a lot of
fun a bit convoluted sometimes if you're
looking for a really new and cool heist
ish movie with mobsters and guns and
Denzel and Mark Wahlberg being badasses
it's not gonna be new content here I'm
not saying I'm gonna buy two guns on
blu-ray but I will say I enjoyed myself
and two guns is a good time no alcohol
required grace or your favorite guns and
mobsters and shoot them up type movie
Pulp Fiction does not count
that's a dialogue based movie really
just you gotta know that what's your
favorite whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
I feel like usually I wouldn't pick this
movie more but I watch Smurfs to like a
day ago so I can watch anything at this
point it's gonna get a free pass I could
watch Paula Deen's hemorrhoid surgery
and I'm gonna be like that is a solid
July movie right there